التي تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه للوصول اليها
لانها منفذ نحو جزيره القرم من القبول هذه
المدينه الواقعه في هذه النقطه كما نشاهد
على الخريطه هذه من التبول الضغط
الاوكراني الان في هذه المعركه تحديدا
معركه سابولوجيا وكما نشاهد على الشاشه
المناطق الحمراء هي مناطق سيطره القوات
الروسيه والمناطق الخضراء هي مناطق سيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه تضغط القوات الاوكرانيه
باتجاه زبولوجيا تحديدا بعد ان استعادت
السيطره خلال الشتاء الماضي او الخريف
الماضي على هذه المناطق من منطقه خيرسون
ورفعت العلم الاوكراني هنا بعد ان انسحبت
القوات الروسيه باتجاه العمق عمق خرسون
نتحدث عن مناطق الجنوبيه بهذه الاهميه
لاننا نتحدث عن الخطوط الواصله نحو شبه
جزيره القرمله التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه منذ عام 2014 وتعتبر هي خطوط
الامداد الرئيسيه للقوات
الخطوط الامداد الرئيسيه للقوات الروسيه
للدخول نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه من جهه
الجنوب لان العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه بدات من شبه جزيره القرم
وهي التي مكنت القوات الروسيه من السيطره
على هذا الشريط الاحمر الذي نشاهده على
الشاشه اذا ما دخلنا في صوره اقرب الى
تحديدا فنحن نتحدث عن هذه المناطق المسافه
بين
المدينه
هنا كما ذكرنا وتسيطر القوات الاوكرانيه
هنا التحرك الاوكراني نتحدث عن حوالي 100
كيلومتر فقط هذه المسافه التي تحتاج
القوات الاوكرانيه للتقدم في العمق تحدث
ايضا عن حوالي 40 كيلومتر فقط بين
ميلتوبول المدينه وبحر ازوف القوات
الاوكرانيه تسعى للوصول الى البحر الى
شواطئ بحر ازوف وبالتالي كسر معادله
السيطره الروسيه على شواطئ بحر ازوف بعد
ان كانت سيطرت على الشواطئ من من اقليم
دنيتك وبالتالي تسعى القوات الاوكرانيه
لعمليات انزال او سيطره في هذه المدينه
المهمه لانها اذا ما وصلت الى هذه النقطه
سيكون الوصول الى البحر مهما وبالتالي كسر
معادله ان هذا البحر اصبح
بحيره في الاراضي الروسيه او في مناطق
سيطره القوات الروسيه والنقطه الثانيه ان
من تبول تقع على الخط الواصل خط سكه
القطار الواصل بين دونيتك والواصل بين
القرن وبالتالي الوصول الى هذه النقطه
يعني ان القوات الاوكرانيه ستكون قادره
على ضرب خطوط الامداد الروسيه القادمه من
شبه جزيره القرن نحو الجنوب بقي نشير
اخيرا بشكل سريع ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقول انها ان هناك ثلاث خطوط للدفاع
الروسي في اقليم انها استطاعت السيطره او
كسر خط الدفاع الاول